happy birthday shohei enjoy your day
it's fun jose suarez has fought his way
all the way back nothing's been handed
to him gooby he's earned this start
tonight enrique hernandez gets the call
the center fielder
elevated fastball that strike three down
goes enrique i really like when you see
jose squires get into that stretch
position he takes that deep breath and
allows his muscles to relax and he's
able to elevate a fastball or turn over
change-ups rafael dever third baseman
the exhale and the fire home fastball
swung right through it 95 miles an hour
that's strike three martin perez in his
17th start of the season david fletcher
leads it off
and first pitch swinging from david
fletcher into right center and [ __ ] runs
it down
route number one great jump on that ball
it brings up shohei ohtani
[Applause]
and he swings through the 3-2 perez
strikes him out two away the change up
down and in
swung over the top of it great location
by martine right there christian arroyo
digs in right-handed hitter duo from
jose suarez and arroyo blast this one
the left field welcome back christian
arroyo there it is
424
feet and a euro step from arroyo crush
this ball fastball on the inner half and
he didn't miss it that's a healthy home
run gonzalez at second doll back at
first back to the top for [ __ ] hernandez
that'll help chase is up and out of the
zone that's twice he has struck out
hernandez and both times on elevated
four seen fastballs and there's two outs
now and it brings up devers two up
it works well for devers he pulls it
into right for a base hit gonzalez
rounds third the throw to the plate is
not gonna get there and devers drives in
gonzales beautiful piece of hidden right
there
rafi didn't try to do too much
nice line drive to right field and with
two outs
marvel he was running on the crack of
the bat first and third with just one
out juan lagar set the plate
lagaris
lifts it to left field
gonzales trickling back
that will score a run iglesias will move
into scoring position you called to get
a run back they did get a run back it's
a great base running move by
jose glacis but look if you see stassi
coming in there there's a play there and
he tags him
swinging a high fly into left center
field hit well back on it is kiki at the
track at the wall enrique leaps and he
makes the play
enrique hernandez just took a home run
away from renjifo what can't [ __ ] do
what a play it keeps the red sox ahead
two to one dylan bundy time now with
this game at a tight two to one here's
the next delivery he swings at this one
and lifts a lazy fly ball into left
field phil gosling is circling under
he'll make the catch in
medium left easy out so one away here in
the fourth bobby dalbeck would be the
next batter
that is a strike outside corner
beautiful downward tilt on that pitch
that is a paint with a breakable that's
the slider
we saw all year last year for dillon
bundy on top of it late break spin
right on the corner call third strike
and a base runner for rafael devers 3-0
devers pulls this one
in the air right center lagaris is back
at the wall it is gone he go 21 for
rafael devers
405 foot bomb
to right center field nice
here's the one two swinging a miss he
struck him out did perez blew him away
with 93
and they're two down fastball he just
unleashed it blew it by stassi right
there and he was late on that swing
here's the pitch strike three called
cutter on the outside corner and that
does it inning over to the red sox have
two on with two out for danny santana
danny santana goes first pitch swinging
and locks it into right center field for
a base hit
bogart scores from second and the red
sox lead by four just a little flick of
the bat right there to right field
didn't try to do too much with it
shooting a soft liner to right center
drops in between them runners at second
and third so nobody out there's the
pitch on its way and it's chopped on the
left side it'll get the runner renifo in
the throw to first by bogarts will get
fletcher
the angels score run on that one and
get a little bit closer it's now five to
two with down by three now with shohei
at the dish
ohtani drops it into left center field
santana comes up with it rojas to the
plate the throw
he is safe
ohtani's at second
gets back safely
oh that was close at the dish vasquez
signaled for another look at it i think
they definitely will get another look at
this this was really close the red sox
will challenge oh he got it on a throw
to the plate from danny santana and he
is out at the plate what a throw from
santana well here's martinez average in
the yale grounds this one on the left
side nifty stopped by iglesias low throw
dug out by walsh inning is over on a 6-3
ground down good job by iglesias to get
to it and a nice job by walsh to dig it
out of the dirt sawamura will work here
in the bottom of the seventh inning
sawamura's 3-2
is strike three call this pitch 98
anthony here's jose rojas at the plate
rojas puts a charge into that one toward
right field enjoy the tour jose
out early today working on his swing
the hard work paying off catches that
out in front and lifts it out pretty
good launch angle
for rojas
santana since coming in has gone one for
two with an rbi single
yeah
fletch's got a long way to go no way no
way
[Applause]
fletch made that play from right field
walsh with an incredible stretch
showing the range
now quickly gets rid of the baseball and
the stretch
by walsh
but what a play by fletch off balance
throw but an accurate throw to first
base now the angels are down to their
final out in this fall game
3-2 switches it into left field for a
base hit it's a 5-4 game
and rojas delivers on first and second
here comes shohei 3-1 to ohtani
it's pulled into the shift arroyos there
and the red sox win avino handles ohtani
and the red sox have won 10 of their
last 11.